hi I'm Tina Shay I'm Vanessa Hudgens I'm
Jordan Fisher and we are three of your
rent live cast boots mini rent my
classmates we're gonna figure out I
guess what a musical musical we are yeah
first question
choose a TV musical adaptation you can't
get enough of grease live The Sound of
Music
Liza's Christ Superstar The Wiz live
hairspray live The Rocky Horror Picture
Show I mean it was magic it was so good
fun and like I would still think it was
good even if we weren't in it totally
absolutely oh so good so I'm gonna
switch it up you know I'm gonna wrap my
boy Brandon superstar very fair enough
next question what would be the best
part of performing on Broadway the
energy the respect the glowing reviews
the applause working with talented
co-stars or the opportunity
I'm gonna say the energy I'm gonna say
the energy - there's nothing more
exciting than being on stage and knowing
that like it's live anything can happen
yeah there's like an internal and rush
that happens absolutely those are the
energy as well hell for all the energy
right okay next question is choose a
vacation destination in between gigs
Chicago Cape Town Berlin New England and
none there's no place I get home well
that can be a big issue yeah like we're
all based in LA but even though we have
home in New York I pick any of these
places yeah come on can we get more
tropical than this I'm gonna say Cape
Town let's go I love you know what I'm
gonna have to say anyway I'm gonna say
Cape Town she was a yet to be made
musical adaptation of a classic movie to
be your star V Hercules mrs. Doubtfire
sixteen Candles Fight Club
eight Mile or pulp fiction I'm pulp
fiction all the way the music in it the
story the characters it's sexy it's
exciting 20 mi Thurman classic dance
number you know I think eight mile I
want to see some more from Eminem songs
I can't talk about mine okay finally
choose a bouquet of flowers you'd want
to receive after a performance the Deaf
candies are they left right I don't know
the names of flowers that's that's
Ellie's favorite it's my girlfriend's
favorite to go with that one the
Patricia roses I mean I'll take it
we all got Chicago there's no doubt you
have an edge to you which is why so many
people are drawn to your seductive yeah
absolutely though you struggle with
relationships seer damn gorgeous and you
know it well I thought it won't be am i
relieved
yeah no comment you don't struggle with
us this is a relationship Rickett
[Music]